[Music]
long-time comic book fans will know that
in the world of superheroes
things are really what they seem and
sometimes you really can't trust what
you're being told
indeed on a number of occasions marvel
has pulled the rug out from under the
fans
for better or for worse infinity war was
arguably the most hotly anticipated
installment of the mcu's third phase
and excitement reached a fever pitch
when that first trailer was released
which ended with a climactic shot of cap
leading the avengers into battle
of course at the time it made perfect
sense that hulk would be among them too
the only problem hulk is nowhere to be
found for most of infinity war
let alone the battle sequences shown in
the trailer at the start of the film
hulk suffers an embarrassing defeat
during a head-to-head battle with thanos
and bruce banner is unable to revert
back into his giant green form
dude you're embarrassing me in front of
the wizard i'm sorry i either i can't or
he won't
like i don't hey stand down keep an eye
on him thank you
in the end grew stuns the hulk buster
suit during the final battle against
thanos forces and the trailer's slo-mo
ensemble shot is nowhere to be found
so why the deception well the russo
brothers have said in interviews
that they purposely crafted the trailers
of their avengers films to minimize
spoilers and keep fans guessing
this included altering smaller details
like thor's eye patch and certain
missing infinity stones on thanos's
gauntlet
inevitably the russo brothers tricked
the fans again with the trailers leading
up to avengers in-game
but this time around most people kinda
expected it
considering in-game might well have been
the most eagerly awaited major movie
release of the last few decades
you can hardly blame the russos for
wanting to keep a tight lid on what plot
developments were going to unfold
that said it's still impressive how
little those trailers gave away about
the movie
most of the shots featured in the
in-game trailers utilize
footage from either the very first
scenes of the movie or a few choice
shots of the final battle
the russo's conservative use of scenes
made sense however
since using unaltered footage from the
film's latter two acts would have likely
spoiled the movie's time heist premise
one of the most noticeable misdirections
in the in-game trailer
was black widow sporting her infinity
war error bob
when in fact she'd gone back to her
natural red color there's also a shot of
thor wielding stormbreaker and the fact
he looks a whole lot slimmer than he
does in the actual movie
marvel's history of avengers level
deceit isn't exclusive to the marvel
cinematic universe though
over the years avid marvel fans have
been lied to countless times through
countless misleading story lines and
retcons
that completely flipped previously
established canon on its head
one such retcon involved captain
america's tragic passing
after the civil war crossover event at
the heart of civil war seven issue
conflict is the superhero registration
act
which requires anyone with superhuman
abilities to trust the us government
with their secret identities
and regulate the presence and actions of
heroes cap
is against the superhero registration
act of course which he sees as a grave
infringement on the rights of people
with superhuman abilities one of his
allies luke cage
even sees the act as akin to slavery
during the dramatic fallout of civil war
steve rogers is assassinated by a
brainwashed sharon carter this sets up
the premise for the death of captain
america which spans 18
issues roger's death had wide-reaching
implications for the marvel universe and
eventually the title of captain america
was passed down to bucky barnes
but these are comic books and apparently
no one ever stays dead
inevitably marvel brought cap back by
saying he hadn't
actually died the gun he was shot with
didn't kill him
but rather suspended him in time in
space it was a nice excuse to bring back
a fan favorite
but it also kind of drains all the
emotional weight from the death of
captain america don't you think
one of the more egregious retcons to
plague the avengers the crossings reveal
that tony stark
has been a traitorous sleeper agent for
kane the conqueror for 30 years went
against literally
everything readers knew about iron man
while retconning heroes as villains for
a short narrative arc is commonplace in
the comics
this instance was especially unpopular
among fans
unlike the other alternate universe evil
twin plots that comic book fans had come
to expect over the
years the crossing saw the real tony
stark readers knew and loved betraying
his friends
and straight up killing people after
three decades of deception
the explanation that kang the conqueror
had been manipulating tony for decades
seemed a little thin not only because of
the rich backstory that had been
thoroughly explored during years of iron
man comics
but also because it completely
disregarded any sense readers had of
tony's character development or morality
except not really marvel quickly
backpedaled on the idea that tony stark
had been manipulated into being an
evil double agent by kang for the entire
history of the marvel universe
instead the avengers forever miniseries
pulled off a double retcon that
explained
that the manipulation of tony had taken
place over several months
not years which only served to confuse
and frustrate readers even more
hail andrew
arguably the most controversial hero to
villain retcon in the marvel universe
began with a now infamous cliffhanger in
captain america steve rogers number one
that sees capp pledging his allegiance
to hydra
throughout the secret empire storyline
it's revealed that rogers was
indoctrinated as a double legion of
hydra since childhood
and had been plotting against the allied
powers since the start
the idea that captain america a
historically anti-nazi hero
created by jewish creators truly sided
with nazi adjacent organization
hydra did not sit well with readers to
say the least
some understandably saw it as downright
offensive to captain america's original
creators and the real-life communities
that have been irreparably harmed by
nazism
in an attempt at damage control marvel
tried to argue that hydra wasn't an
explicitly nazi organization
and that cap's hail hydra moment
wouldn't be trivialized with a
bait-and-switch narrative involving
alternate timeline versions of rogers
critics argued however that while
hydra's origins might have predated
nazism in the comics
their ideologies had since become
intertwined now the truth behind cap's
secret hydra allegiance is a little more
complicated than it first appears
with the cosmic cube altering both
reality and steve's memories
still secret empire rewrites history and
says that the hero captain america
readers thought they knew
was the biggest lie of all and that
hydra cap is roger's original form
at the end of secret empire the story
climaxes in a battle between different
versions of steve rogers
the heroic steve wins out of course but
that didn't change much of what had
happened
and the whole storyline still stung for
plenty of captain america fans
in black widow's first origin story
natasha ramanov danced as a ballerina
for the russian bolshoi
before her time as a kgb spy turned
avenger for the earliest black widow
storylines
readers learned that she married a
soviet agent and carried on as a
prominent ballerina but later pledged a
loyalty to the kgb
and trained as a spy after the death of
her husband black widow's dancer past
was even alluded to in the mcu during
scenes from avengers age of ultron
but the truth behind black widow's
backstory was far
more sinister than either the original
tragic origins or its mcu interpretation
in the comics the reality of black
widow's past is that natasha was
brainwashed
trained and biotechnically altered to be
a cold-blooded assassin from childhood
by a soviet program known as the red
room fans pointed out that being a
member of an internationally recognized
dance company
might make it difficult to moonlight as
an assassin but this was easily
explained away by saying that all of
natasha's memories of the ballet had
never happened
instead the false narrative natasha
initially believed about her past was
planted by the red room
to ensure her loyalty to the kgb
remember this particular deception too
because the lies natasha was told about
her past will likely be crucial to the
plot of the upcoming black widow movie
scarlet witch's backstory has been
retconned almost too many times to count
an integral part of wanda's origin
one that people took for granted for
decades was that she and her brother
quicksilver were magneto's children
their mutant powers being inherited
through birth as scarlet witch would
later star as an avenger in the marvel
cinematic universe this posed problems
for disney and marvel
since at the time fox owned the rights
to the x-men and most mutant characters
when marvel fans were introduced to
wanda in avengers age of ultron
her powers are shown to be the results
of experiments by hydra
not mutant genes there's nothing more
horrifying
than a miracle
then in 2014 marvel turned scarlet
witch's origin story on its head
during the axis comics crossover event
wanda discovers
she's not actually magneto's daughter
rewriting the fraught birth and
childhood of the twins once again
this retcon also revealed that readers
had been lied to about the origins of
scarlet witch's powers
she had previously been depicted as
having some magical powers along with
her mutant abilities but the reveal that
her biological connection to magneto was
a lie reinforced marvel's growing
emphasis on her sorcery
essentially marvel took all the mutant
out of one of its most famous mutants
back in the first guardians of the
galaxy movie thanos adopted daughter
gamora
is introduced as the last member of a
species called the zeho berry
now many fans might not remember that
specific detail and that's probably just
what marvel is hoping for
because they later took her origin story
in an entirely different direction
as explained in infinity war thanos was
indeed responsible for the destruction
of her people but it doesn't seem like
he actually
slaughtered all of them as she claimed
in guardians instead
thanos is shown in a flashback sequence
making gamora's planet a stop on his
long quest to bring balance to the
universe
by wiping out half of all life there of
course it's entirely possible that the
rest of the zeoberry had perished
between the events of the infinity war
flashback and guardians of the galaxy
if that's the case however there hasn't
been any explicit
on-screen explanation to that effect
either way
gamora's story is tragic and she had
plenty of reasons to want thanos stopped
at all costs
but this seems like one of those rare
occasions when marvel hadn't really
figured out the specific details of its
sprawling cinematic universe
it doesn't happen often but it appears
that in this instance
feige and his creative team made changes
on the fly hoping most members of the
audience would be too caught up in the
action to notice
avengers age of ultron isn't generally
regarded as one of the best entries in
the mcu
but it has its strong points including
the closing moments of the film
when the hulk commandeers and avengers
quinjet and heads off for parts unknown
he later turns up on sakhar and thor
ragnarok as a sort of gladiatorial
all-star who battles new contenders for
the amusement of the grand master
it's basically the mcu's version of the
classic planet hulk
storyline from the comics and a turn of
events that fans had long been clamoring
for
it also wasn't initially supposed to be
that way as marvel studios
chief kevin feige later admitted when
ultron was made
the mcu brain trust had no idea where
hulk would end up but they explicitly
told age of ultron director joss whedon
that he wouldn't be going to space
feige explains if you go back and look
at that shot of the movie
he's in the sky it's blue sky in the
movie it's we lost the signal out by the
caspian sea
or something like that it was all
earthbound here's one case in which it
seems safe to assume
that most marvel fans can forgive the
studio for a little shift in direction
after all their change of heart gave us
thor ragnarok
and who could possibly argue with that
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about
marvel are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one